[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link it's time for another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet at the roundtable of
dim lighting this week we have Flula
Borg German techno DJ and producer with
a major YouTube presence an extremely
dedicated cult following now he's hosted
a number of shows on a number of
channels like what's trending machinima
screen junkies to name a few but his own
YouTube channel which he started in 2007
boasts over 330 thousand subscribers and
over 44 million views now we really like
Flula let's go ahead and just come clean
here we were really like flew from the
first time we met I mean we met him at
VidCon he came up and introduced himself
and we just were immediately drawn to
this guy's personality he's hilarious
charismatic yes happy and I would say
unorthodox and I don't think it's just
because he's from Germany but but he he
I'd say he does get a lot of mileage out
of than he does but I I think he's just
he's just a different dude as is
evidenced by one of his first hit songs
which we're gonna play for you here it's
called moo moo cow
you are so dairy
[Music]
now if Lula's first viral success on his
YouTube channel were his vlogs where he
articulated his confusion around
American idioms okay so his most viewed
video to date almost at 5 million views
is called Jennifer is a party pooper 7
12 a.m.
Jennifer goes to the party and then
poops but she do it so people's know
with where do she go for it does she
does she visit a water closet and make
door of the open so people may see and
smell things maybe she go like by the
tables with gift and a present and two
punches both Jennifer you have some
mental issue and he's moved beyond the
vlogs to successful series like auto
tunes with Flula which is a play on
words in which he records an entire
acapella cover yeah he does like a look
he has his looping machine right and
usually the auto collaborates with
different YouTube guests you know he's
worked with grace he's worked with
Hannah he worked with Miranda sings and
a really popular I think is most popular
auto-tune so far is the no diggity cover
with Chester
[Music]
[Music]
so we're glad to have Flula sit in with
us here and make an ear biscuit I was
personally very interested in the story
of how he made the collaboration with
Sir mix-a-lot happen mm-hmm baby got
back we also talked about his backstory
growing up in Germany that was that a
pun on his baby got back story in
Germany coming to America which is a
movie but it's also the story of Flula
coming to America including his stint as
a mascot at the much-hated and around
here on your biscuits school UNC and we
asked the $64 question or the $25,000
pyramid
I think it's $64,000 question is 64
million dollar question if he knows why
he's funny does he know that he's funny
at all so we'd we'd open to that here it
is the Flula biscuit warming it up you
talk about criss cross you know it's my
ex-girlfriend I was almost in a
relationship with half of criss cross I
don't know if it's to have to died or
not Oh doc Oh doc turn pretty early whoa
which which one died cross is Chris you
were following this well I know dad both
Chris's right they're both Chris's I
think Chris Samsung and they wore their
they wore their outfits backwards they
were totally crossed out now I knew when
I said warming it up that you were gonna
latch on to that just like we were
talking about working on something
together and I think we've settled on
you're gonna let us be in your video
with the salt and pepper push it like
you would go to a spa
yeah I mean absolutely we want to be let
us on you know this is my honor this is
like a free box of pop-tarts if you gave
me this I would eat all of those yeah I
mean you seem to be steeped in I'm
trying to put parameters on the music on
the either the genre or the time period
because I think we're similar in age
yeah so what what music are you obsessed
with 1/2 of sessions with I think it's
terrible music from the early 1990s 90s
it is when you do not have taste yet as
a child and just always it on the radio
this means it's great and so I love it
so like 1999 t 2 3 4 I'm loving all of
the old hip hop so I really love this
very much I listen to you 93.5 here clay
de que de oh I love it
they play the old-school rap and I was
93.5 yeah they were only the first all
tune in first stations to play first hip
hop stations in America back in the day
but they still play the old-school stuff
and my kids were in the car and they
were playing that that jam at the
playground and it's the kids at the
playground da da da da da da that's
another bad creation ABC oh yeah they're
also saying Ayesha Ayesha and what you
know I want you so bad
not about him don't mean a Buddha they
also had a song called spider-man which
sounds like Aisha accepts it just say
spider-man got a hook recycle it the
psychic kids when that song went off the
radio my kids don't understand the radio
because they're in a digital age and
Lincoln was like dad played the song
again and I was like it's on it was on
the radio and he did not understand that
I couldn't play it again when did this
happen recently
two weeks ago and then then he was like
play that playground song again that was
cool as kids rapping I was like I can't
play it again it was on the thing called
the radio that we'd never listened to
Wow
and then he said well download it so no
I got it you know in the moment he was I
was downloaded from the radio but you're
saying just later download it well the
fact is I could have downloaded it
immediately of course on my phone you
but not to the radio I wasn't used to be
120 I informed about this well speaking
of music
Flula you've been quoted as saying about
your own music yeah
my music is like a hamster who has been
fed some magic juice the hamster is
looking strange in the eyes yes which is
probable from the juice and the people
are saying dance hamster dance from your
hamster legs and now a secret
I am the hamster yeah then you uh can
you put that in layman's terms in who
terms yeah that means make that in a way
say that in a way that normal people can
understand I I'm a person who is like do
you know like a sponge let us know on
yeah let us we add a supermarket we have
purchased a sponge what isn't a sponge
right now here nothing he are serious
right so you put a sponge into earth and
everything is coming to the sponge you
squeeze it you squash it and dirt out
dirt and sound and poodles and
everything is going into this sponge
right unlike the sponge and then the old
man is walking a by and then he does not
see to sponge it small he stepped on the
sponge what is occurring it all comes
out okay what genre is your music I mean
you're a DJ well as you invent music
yeah DJ is tough it is everyone is a
teacher now right you're like oh who are
you a Thomas great you're a DJ you know
it doesn't matter anybody can get on
teacher Thomas is a hot name but I like
to make weird sounds and sounds well
they're not with people say they are
weird I find things that are interesting
and then I just make loops with those
and I like to express well you take a
pound like anything that is in my brain
I'll bring it out everyone is you eyes
doing this you guys are making videos
you know this is this is true but I
think this I don't know if I would
describe our work as a hamster I think
that's one of the one of the key
differences what what you said trouble
maybe I don't know if I would use any
small for and we've never sampled cows
mooing yeah oh yeah we did hear your
your track what was that
well two names Koshien which means tiny
cow or a cake if you pronouncing it
different or moo moo cow for the
American audience but it had a tagline
that was like you are so dairy yeah a
moo moo cow you are so dairy you are a
heifer ferry and what you did you right
did you write that I did write it as a
child but it was before I was
understanding how to write techno songs
so I have it I have a tiny book where it
is many poems as a child and then I was
taking these poems and making techno
songs when I learned a very crappy
software called EJ EJ which is Vijay why
it's terrible but then I was using this
to make dope techno tunes as a child as
a that was like 17 18 years old okay
yeah but the poems are nine years old
ten years old okay yeah yeah yeah but
that was like one of your one of the
first songs to kind of like be like oh
this guy is an artist I don't got a song
about a cow yeah about cows about cows
and I was sampling two cows I live in as
I'm from a small town close to noon back
nürnberg has a set history for Americans
it is the trials place of the trials
Deborah downer
you know trial do you know yeah not like
Matlock or what but yeah yeah Herman so
I but this I was working some summers in
garmisch-partenkirchen which is in
Bavaria and then you we can ski there
many winters there cows are there many
many many cows so I was recording those
cows and then yeah sampling okay so I
want let's come back yeah welcome back
to the campus sampling as a child or
writing poems as a child but I did want
to pick your brain about not only your
music but your video with sir mix-a-lot
[Music]
we love all of the auto tunes all thanks
and that's what we really want to be in
one
just push it thing let's make it happen
we are doing a super excited oh yeah
love the Chester c1 I mean I knew that
you know okay
just reading the title no diggity with
Chester see no I'm not surprised that it
blew up as big as it did I mean it's in
your top 5 performing videos at least
for now I think you know things are
still blowing up for you but it was so
it was so satisfying when he when he
drops when he starts singing oh I was it
was just smart the way that you set it
up well yeah well that we did not have
so much planning I just said hey but
maybe I you're a taxi an uber right and
then he said uber blend I said let's
record and then tweeted to it too but
you knew I mean that he would the
tension was gonna build to him like
busting out into that chorus that hook
Chester see just got boys she's got the
pipe pipe sees having pipes so I do not
own pipes don't know yeah you were the
perfect setup it was like the tension
was building to a line you know I can't
wait for that no diggity chorus well he
can well and I also I love this song it
is one of my most favorite songs and I'm
very happy he did like it he's really
into it enjoy it yeah it's like
volleyball like bump
I was bumping and then he was volume he
was ready for it wasn't like oh you know
that saw no digging he was like let me
familiarize myself with it it wasn't one
of these situations like on American
Idol where these kids are singing a song
that we all know by heart and you could
be like oh they've heard it twice oh no
he knew it he was empty in the bounce
and bounce with the pipes but I wanted
to ask about the sir mix-a-lot baby got
back
auto-tuned yeah yeah yeah how did you
how did that come about well as it I
love sir mix-a-lot very much that it is
his song is one top 10 hip hop songs
icing in the history so this is this is
ubiquitous alright everywhere so I love
it
in Twitter we have a friend we are
sharing a friend me and end in sir
mix-a-lot and so one time she was his
friend like I celebrity no no well yeah
she is it's miss Destructo at miss
Destructo amber Osbourne she's very top
she's like a very she's like a social
media guru expert person and we have
connected some years ago and one time
she read and makes a tweet like hey
Flula and mix-a-lot you guys are cool or
something like this or very nice and I
see it immediate I did not realize he
was on Twitter one tweet to both of you
yeah and I immediately started pump we
have to matchmaker oh yeah and then I we
are following each other and I'm
directness a mr. Mike started following
you at that point oh yeah we did it
because she was up my friend and his
friend also and then I said you know mr.
mix-a-lot I think I said sir I don't
know if I say I've said I said something
formal maybe he already was sir you
might as well go with it right so I did
maybe was like sir mix-a-lot I would
drive to your house if you do not are
scared of me and we will record a song
let us a direct message yet direct
message and then he's like yeah great I
think he's probably receiving many
things in life that he's like yeah
whatever but I was like yeah boom this
is the time this is the day I have to
call let's do it and then he's like yeah
this sounds boring let's do it different
and then I said well what if it has some
dubstep he's like boom let's do it so
then he said yes he's local
no he's in Seattle Seattle so you drove
from Los Angeles to Seattle yeah because
you could you said I will drive to your
house yeah I didn't not care where he
was living
yeah does not matter so yeah he gives
you the over Twitter you're gonna you
figure out you had to add dubstep into
the mix in order for him to be
interested yeah because he's like you
know this is I've seen too so many
million times I need some hello let's
try something fresh please you know and
I understand if it if I am a mr. Cermak
a lot this is boring let's try some new
things so we did it so you drove up
there yeah and what was that initial
meeting like knock on the door type
thing or was there a gate there was a
gate he was not saying he's like oh
sorry at the pharmacy which was great I
was like oh he's a human he purchases
aspirins that is nice so I did wait and
then he did arrive and then we go inside
he chose me studio and then we shoot in
what is sir mix-a-lot house like very
nice nice dope dope dope mention is that
big buck money no you know big booty big
booty pay still coming in like in
fountains inside type situation outside
I did not see inside perhaps dewater was
off but there was a statue of himself no
that would be cool though ah next time
next time but then you know I got more
so and but then you you know the
parameters are you have to shoot this is
like your rental car your car rented
rental car yeah rental car ah yeah a
superb more what yeah but usually the
car my car didn't move with mix-a-lot no
but two Vipers did is that because he
what he was like let's just keep let's
just stay stationary no it just it was
raining you had to make it happen yeah
yeah yeah and we also didn't have like a
driver and I was thinking maybe you just
come in like I will pop up a pop up and
then you enter and then we will start
and it was okay I think it's nice to not
move if you have a nice person like that
like if it's only me maybe better to
drive or have like yeah chickens outside
or something something outside yeah that
worked out pretty great there Wow
I was very lucky and happy about it he
is also de bomb he's so cool
so he's easy to work with oh wow so
great he's a producer and so he under I
don't know he's just great very great
person yeah do you keep in touch now
little bit yeah I like after Seahawks at
its text to him because he is a pig
mister like a Seattle Seahawks to
football he loves it so I we will text
and hey great work boo-boom boo-boom and
and he says something not done from him
la face with the Oakland booty
what about that's so good
what you
favorite auto-tune that you've done so
far oh that's tough I like many of those
in my mind right now to answer its
perhaps because it's NBA playoffs I did
Auto Tunes with Dirk Nowitzki oh yeah
who is it in a couple of ladies some
some nice ladies their archi leader
spirits yeah and for the metrics and so
he did sing a Rolling Stones
satisfaction which is a song yeah in in
Dirk he's uh he can sing okay dick can
he's like a wizard of every all the
items he's a jack of all trades all of
the jacks is a very big man he's a large
person in the backseat of that car
oh you stand out a little bit it was
awkward yeah yeah
you added all this to I assume right I
do as a in editing exercise it is a lot
of exercise it is a lot but I enjoyed to
do it it's a nice it's a it's create a
few guys I think are knowing it editing
is like this is where you make your
breads like you purchase two angry you
know like you purchase the flour and
bread and butter bread and butter yeah
so let's just find out we know where
you're at now right so you're here in LA
you're you're making a go at it as a DJ
now you've got the YouTube thing that's
that caught our attention just know in
the past year or so great big fans
wanted you to be a part of them
the belly button video thanks for doing
that thank know thank you guys that was
so very fun and yeah and want to be part
of an auto-tuned of course let's go back
let's go back to the beginning boom boom
so how does how does what worthy was the
origins of Flula you know where were you
born
how did that happen were your parents
like parents did make a metric time but
it was an Iranian which is a small town
near to Nuremberg and Americans like
Erlang and is how you were spell it but
Erlangen earlier yeah yeah yeah
so I'm a spawn Thea it's in Bavaria it's
north Bavaria and I I always did like
music always I was always beatboxing I
have no brothers or sisters or anything
like that so when I'm alone it's like
duplicate tickets so always making
sounds and weird and drawing things and
I think always I was feeling like I must
ah I have to get it out it's like like a
power moving part of good times yeah and
so this is I think my start was I have
to release it what occurs if you do not
release it how do your parents
articulate this now back to you we
thought you were weird or yeah they are
I think now they are okay was it before
a little concern a little bit was
concerned like what's occurring what are
you doing they would wanted me to make
cuz I was like an engineering major
little bit so they like it let's do this
you aren't standing mass please let's
let's follow this they'll get a real job
real jobs their understanding this path
better but for me it's a okay that's
good but I do not feel for me personal
it is right I need something different
now I was I was an only child
well agar I was a stepsister until third
grade and then my mom and Jimmy split up
and then it was from third grade on it
was just me and my mom so I was
basically living with no siblings and I
remember I would play solitaire on my
bed actually I wouldn't I got that wrong
I would play poker and against myself
with cards on my bed stop it
like well that's all right I would play
poker against myself as a kid who wanted
yeah I don't remember but maybe I should
have been beatboxing but why look what
was occurring now we're wearing
headphones and speaking yeah I don't
play cards yeah I worked at all I didn't
have a future in cards but as crazy as
it seems it seems like you were onto
something
well I did not know it I think yeah I
don't know yeah it's but what was in
terms of every all the music that we
were listening to here in America were
you pretty much being exposed to the
same stuff so like that that late 80s
early 90s where I remember when we were
in middle school we started beatboxing
you know there would be beatbox contests
Wow on the playground at the playground
so this kind of stuff was happening in
Germany - well no not so much I must say
and I will tell you I'm not like an
expert of beatboxing I just enjoy it
so I make a do it it is like a man who
enjoys yoga he is not like in the yoke
Olympics he's just doing down for talks
oh [ __ ] you didn't have like I mean we
had like I mean the real story was is
that we were two white kids that wanted
to be able to beatbox like all the black
kids that we went to school with and
ayah and we would just watch them and
listen to them and then try to emulate
them and it was like oh I think I can
figure out what they're doing and now
let's now let's do it and now let's
practice and let's kind of push each
other push it but what I mean what-what
were you how are you you just like
trying things out moving your mouth
around and yeah yeah I was doing that
today sir
old banter called The Fat Boys yeah yeah
and they have one song
it's average I don't know if it's a lot
of bits it's called my nuts
shall we say that here yeah man is this
[Music]
is a crazy one yeah yeah yeah I was
always trying to do this a little bit
but in my school not so many people we
are liking American culture it is it's
still access in Germany but as a child
we have obsessing with everything and it
was like a perfect time because Michael
Jordan was pick and so we are I love
basketball a lot and so that was like
many culture things are coming to to us
in this time like Michael Jackson
Dangerous album this was a very big
thing also so we did I was listening to
all of these things and I was trying to
make a copy of it for sure but not
everyone was like that I must say yeah
okay and were you at this time like
recording your stuff like inventing
stuff come you know producing your own
music saying you were writing poems yeah
I was writing poems as a child so I
would write the poems and then it was
you know how we have like a phases like
after moon but longer and and for your
life no
so liked it I was like writing poems for
like three years and then I did not know
where's the book who knows time to
collect stamps but then I would find the
book and oh wow this is a cool cool poem
about cows and now I have some techno is
of
we're let's make a song and what are
some of the lyrics to that to the the
Derry song whatever it's called yeah moo
moo cow yes you are naked know what oh
yeah
moo moo cow you are so teri you are a
heifer fairy that's my most popular line
in this I can see why moo moo cow yes
you are sacred you are black and white
and naked okay so here's a question yeah
do you know how funny that is no I only
am writing things i sink making sense
and are fun time and maybe it's a
rhyming or sounding cotton inside
boom let's do it because I'm gonna this
is I'm gonna tell ya I perceive that
what I hear that
moo moo cow you are so dairy what what's
next you are a half a fairy or a heifer
fairy I'm like okay this guy is
hilarious
this this is a and this guy's a little
crazy
perhaps a people have said it instead
that's me and then I think and that's
why I like him and I think that's why
everyone else likes him are you do you
you see how people latch on to that
because this song got kind of popular
right a little bit yeah it was a little
bit it was yeah I don't know what when
it happened what would we like oh they
liked the hook or where they did you
think oh no they they must understand
that I'm funny I don't understand comedy
really I'm only making items that I must
make you know like you feel it the
pressure it is like helmet let us eat
you are we are here with ear biscuits
let us have 15 biscuits
well these may not just live in your in
your in your in your place yeah at some
time they must come out so if I'm seeing
too many cows on the street in the
pastures I must record a song with the
cows and then I must release this song
and was this a breakout here I mean what
what was the I'm trying to figure out
where in the journey something popped
for you because at some point you come
here to the states which came first
entertainment or the move what wasn't
what was the next yeah so I was DJing in
Germany first and I was I was
well okay so to start I was a
schuhplattler a dancer and so
schuhplattler is like the you know the
early early early like I cannot Yuri but
schuhplattler awesome and Etta wearing
the lederhosen and slapping legs and
feet we cannot show in a podcast because
it is for years like a fork dancer
yeah yeah yeah and we are calling a
schuhplattler so I was a schuhplattler
in a group and I was doing this you were
a dancer and tradition a traditional
German dance that's right yeah yeah so
more like is like Bavarian a little bit
and so I was doing says thank you a
dress like a yodeler well with
lederhosen and we all were you do this
at like at first of all luzon yeah we
have a clap with a person club undone
sorry then we go and we will have like a
defense we will have at folks vests
which just means like to people people
parties like a fair a fear a fear yeah
but we do not have like the large pigs
and you're like oh
chicken fried dumpling a hot dog in the
Twinkie chocolate right yeah we don't
have this head dancing and waffles yeah
yeah and so we will do it at these
parties or sometimes it's just only for
practice you know it's like old people
are like let's have invoice club let's
voice together old ladies we had this
with a schuhplattler so I was starting
with this we have a tea tray and I was
speaking to him about DJ times music and
that this is my start of making some
music and so then I was making music but
it was like it not like it good tape
recorder like a quarter of tape say like
yeah yeah boom and 10/10 blah blah blah
blah right this is something I'm
speaking too many words now no I got you
then I was making more some techno songs
and then the cow song was a starter many
of some that I was making okay the video
was helping this is before you to budget
writes a song many ways you made a video
with it yeah yeah yeah yeah and where do
you put the video well before it was not
on YouTube it was like on my page in
some way it was like an old video on old
website and then when YouTube was like a
blip I will pump it up I will I will
upload it just for a fun time and so
yeah but it involved a table
an actual cattle cows
yeah cows yeah yeah but what was the
video the video was I did have some
friends and I also a suit for cows and
so I did dress with the cow suit and
then we did just film it and this isn't
on you channel now though yeah yeah you
may see it I did make a re-release it
was a yah yah it was it was feelin
little like mmm sauce like let's make it
let's make it a little more better so I
did I learned some editing and then
remix remix yeah yeah yeah I'm just
trying to figure out so you put that on
YouTube yeah and then when did you when
did you get to the States
so I when did and when did the YouTube
traction start to come or was it music
traction first so I was always working
here in Germany sorry a little bit then
I did my okay so this is crazy but my
friend David Giuntoli you may not know
this person but perhaps some listeners
will know him he is on the show grim on
NBC it is a monster show he's an actor
he was backpacking some years ago in in
Germany and we did meet with like PSPs
bla bla bla he's like you should come
too you know
come visit sometime and then so I did so
I did visit with him in Los Angeles some
years ago like six years ago seven years
ago with my cousin and we did live on
his on his balcony was in a tent for a
little bit yeah what yeah you lived in a
tent yeah and the on the balcony of the
dude from Grimm television shows house
before but this is before he was like a
big actor person like he was just I
think just making like auditions for
like commercials just a guy with the
balcony at that point you had him
backpacking in Germany he was
backpacking yeah and I was working as a
teacher I ate at a zone halfway house
like a like a party house
a peer house and then he was like hey
Jew has his song played his song and
then we start talking and then I realize
he's American and he's from San Luis st.
Louis and I have obsession a little bit
I do not know why but like they have
like this Aussie Aussie something
from baseball and I like he makes weird
flips he Smith yeah flipper flipper and
I was like dint if we start talking and
PS are occurring and then boom he's like
come you must find me when you know when
you are coming to America and you did he
didn't think you would I don't know yeah
he later he said why I do not know why
why did this occur he was was a surprise
forgot I think so but he lets you sleep
on his balcony in a tent for five months
okay with another guy was another guy my
cousin yeah yeah and then yeah and then
this is so this was my first like let's
make me and then this was when I
realized I must come to America because
America and my brain is like a megaphone
right if you want to spread your
energies to the world Los Angeles is a
place where you may do it you make it
here and people can hear all your things
it's not different with YouTube you can
make upload and Snoopy Schnabel Dingle
dunk what is this place who cares do
they have internet perfect you may
upload right but before it was a place
in LA yeah but hold on because you told
us about the whole mascot at the Tar
Heel mascot yeah yeah so you gotta tell
us how that fits into this whole thing
yeah being graduate from NC State our
archrival
at least in our minds are the UNC thar
hills
yeah ooh and UNC Tar Heel mines arch
rivals are Duke University Blue Devils
but we well if we have to get into that
we will yeah yeah but first you got to
tell us that you were the Tar Heel
mascot for yeah for what yeah for eight
games yeah yeah I was not fire I would
this is before this is before the LA
thing or after this is so this is
college time so I've been to America you
know sometimes some some you know and
when I was in college in Germany we did
exchange so I had one semester in Chapel
Hill in North Carolina and so I like to
explore many weird things and this was I
have my friend he was on the same
dormitory he was some tours down and he
was the mascot he was the UNC Tar Heel
ramasees remedies remedies yeah and so I
did see it and
I said I said Todd way I have to do this
take your job yeah but no one will know
because I mean we're in a suit we're
very masks I mean problem is I'm you
know 35 centimeters taller than Todd so
some people will know and the mezco
suits mascot suit not made for peoples
as you know yeah tall dudes told you
it's not good for the suit crotch crotch
precious so how did you did you wear
this the same of course this was this
this is like a clandestine this was a
this was under the table operation where
you slipped into the suit with no one no
permission but well I thought Such yes
oh wow this is this is you have to jump
around and stay you have to know you
know jump up jump up and whatnot just
that though but there's a certain level
of respect for the position that there's
probably somebody out there some might
you know my brother graduated from from
Carolina oh that's oh sorry that's how
does this work in your brain well I mean
you know bitterness yeah we don't talk
about it okay we don't talk about that
yeah yeah under rocks under rocks not to
mention that your wife graduated from
yeah yeah you dated her while she was
still attending yeah and I gave you I
can hard time about that block that I
blocked that up but but what I'm saying
I'm using my brother as an example
because my wife doesn't care about UNC
sports ah at all
yeah you know a little bit but but
there's this like oh hold on you were
Ramses and you were basically you know
it was like link said it was clandestine
no one knew that you were doing it oh
you disrespected the position oh I say
no because I was bringing many heart
energies I was burning many calories and
I did study you know I was watching all
the game watching Todd what does he -
how does he hold a baby
how does he say go team you had to hold
babies - times yeah Wow but a dangerous
day baby hole it is a problem for the
lawsuits so yeah so I did learn very
fast you have any kids cry because you
got close to him
no no one one baby actually it is an NC
state man slept at a trial
I was like walking around like lalala Go
Go Go Go Tar Heels and then the the
mascot suit make a rotation so the eyes
are now where my ears are now living and
so I cannot see I'm I am blind and then
I make an ax just put a helmet backs and
I see and it is a child whose red in the
face from the paint he's maybe eight
years old and give me double Birds we
hate the Tarheels
I think that's right you flew the ball
Thanks like I said I like you that you
you you stole into the costume I do like
that yeah look you were them you were
that you were the RAM during basketball
games basketball games stop as me that's
big time I hope to think so I was really
enjoying it a halftime show you were
like cavorting out there in the middle
who isn't there's some sort of
choreography involved in this well that
the matter hem see the suit the head is
a very large thing it is not like for
flipping like I've seen other like you
know like the mascots in the np8 it's
like time for honking honking - yeah
yeah the Dempsey mascot is like mom he's
like like a large marshmallow person
he's like the kool-aid boy what he's
like what what may he do he can pass the
balls he can pass the wall and and serve
a beverage right this is how the baby
should Hannon t-shirt cannon oh no this
is no we had no cannons so as to
cheerleaders a flippy-flippy
I can just go yeah number one number one
and then go into crowds high five five
you like facing the wrong direction
yeah where you found out no you just
gave it up you're like two sweaty in
here it was very hot and Farris it's
much sweat perspiring severy place yeah
in towers like I want my job back
we're in the sewer drain well and only
was the deal was and we sometimes
trading it so I was second half he was
like I will sweat very hot inside you
will not go first half deny have to live
in your perspiring yeah it was a sloppy
as you say what sloppy sloppy I don't
say that okay
someone is saying it Wow you never got
in trouble no no and then did you
degree or you went back to Germany oh
yeah that was changed one semester so
yeah I saw my degree was an engineering
degree yeah yeah we have that in common
that's the 300 NC State it's engineers
both of us have a degree so we should I
mean we should engineer something the
three of us could do something yes you
get an engineering degree
did you finish yeah I did finish but I
did not use it immediately one do you
have environmental engineering oh yeah
yeah can we cover everything what are
you guys civil and industrial thrilling
oh we can build a pony yes you can build
a working phone let's build a pony
yeah get in it for the second half
second half pony toy it's gonna be
mechanical and you're able to get it to
two you know two of us you know what two
of us can get inside of it and one of us
can ride it I have seen your pony I've
seen your pony fit to help zebra yeah
yeah let's see press sorry and that
wasn't us inside it oh we made it seem
like it was that wasn't smart for guys
outsourcing
okay so fast REE fast-forward back to
sleeping on the tent in Los Angeles is
this when things started to snowball for
you we were it was a time when I was
thinking we must come to Los Angeles and
so we did do it and we have some videos
of this time I was thinking I must come
here to make a spread of my music but
what was his sad time is I did not think
about visas and legal issues and so I
was deported deported and it did not
take so long it was four months five
months and sent Bombeck Germany okay and
that's when you see the video early on
if you can't meet a DJ visa
well yeah I'm in Germany and then you're
with your that's your grandfather yeah
my oppa my grandfather and then though
some poodles of my parents and then do
now which is a Turkish very tasty nice
food and in bread also so you kind of
mean that a song but right like when you
are like you know it guys when you are
when you are feel depression what occurs
for you guys you want the things of home
right you are missing two home times
I'll eat some ice cream but a donor or
whatever it is
and you would like a meat it's meat yeah
it is meat meat with a nice house in a
nice little flattened hood which is like
a bread time and then you have like I'm
sorry if onions do if you like it ha ha
so but you made your way back to LA it
didn't take the deportation yeah so now
at then I then I was away for some years
now
for and always travels so if I have drop
I will come back to America and if it's
a hosting or music or what but now for
two years I'm now living a little bit
more in Los Angeles what was the what
was the breakout what was the thing that
you started getting hosting gigs what
what what what was the big thing that
popped DJ DJ music kicks and also
hosting because because I'm so not I
think they were like oh you are you are
different so here's a job and so I would
make hosting drops of like pedal of the
pants do you know battles like it's a
battle of the pants he is who's gonna
win it I don't know and for some reason
I don't know not know why did it hire me
to make a host of these things for well
okay in that neck goes back to kind of
what I was saying before with the with
the perception of you know like the the
the cow song so it's just like I think
what people see is they're like oh hey
let's get this let's get Flula he's
German
he's he's kind of crazy I mean I love
the way he talks
I mean clueless do you have you ever
have you ever heard or read people
described you would they say something
harsh
you mean like the film clueless yeah
like if they would say that oh this
guy's from Germany he don't know how to
speak English isn't he funny yeah let's
do a battle and people taking advantage
of you is what I'm saying like do you
think that people are like oh let's
bring him into this scenario where you
know he doesn't know he doesn't know why
he's been funny right now
I uh well for me it is if you are giving
me a drop who's caring I don't know is
it a drop rate does it pay some dollars
or Euros or
who cares our hard drive papé aim to me
something great you eat in a hard drive
yeah a Seagate 250 gigabyte hot rod
whatever it was the college bad laughter
pants they they were like that they
needed a host and they paid you in a
hard drive one well I did negotiate for
two after the start the end because I
know I did do a good job so I said this
was great what was it good
may I have another hard drive so it was
- okay yeah right so you so you don't
concern yourself with that you're just
like I'm here I'm having a good time and
I'm not thinking too much about why
people might be asking me to do this
because because I just as somebody who's
observing your career I'm thinking you
know I know why we were like you know
what we we should get Flula be to be in
this video because I was just thinking
you know what let's just give Flula a
phone and let him be himself and we know
it's gonna be funny
oh great we know it's gonna be funny
yeah and it totally worked
Oh coach and then when you if you know a
lot of people will give you will give
this away now you click on links face at
the end of the bellybutton video you go
to the secret video which is Flula just
add living at the end and it was I mean
everyone on set was having a very
difficult time containing themselves as
you were just being yourself oh that's
nice
and so I'm saying that's how we proceed
it I uh I don't
yeah I mean you hang it up well
sometimes I go I go to a world right
like if something Sakura you guys you
like hey you you must teach us about
bellybuttons what has occurred well then
I just go into my brain and I enter a
world and I just speak from that place I
don't really know what's occurring if
you are liking it that's very great but
I have also been to places where like we
hate you used you suck a lot you know
suck a large cheeseball you know do not
get a hard drive today yeah no hard
drives for you sorry I won that yeah use
the cloud but was there a point
you were like oh oh I said okay these
Americans are these Americans are really
digging this
they're digging what I'm a so yeah when
I do this cow song when I do this when
I'm dancing this way and then you're
like oh I can keep doing this and I can
get more successful and I can have a
career in entertainment like was there a
point where you were like that's kind of
click oh yeah so I like it's maybe you
guys too proper like when I see a people
are liking something like if I perceives
many feels like I made a vlog I did make
a vlog about daddy longlegs dis insect
yeah it did receive all in certain many
views so I was thinking oh people enjoy
vlogs from from me great I shall make
more vlogs like the party pooper so
haughty pooper
yeah yeah a pooper was the after the
daddy longlegs after yeah yeah yeah
party poopers like that number one video
for me it is the most yeah and it
address was a now forty flocks I just if
something has hit me hit me like oh I
sure this is this is in my brain weird
let's make a flock about it and then I
release and some who know stay to
receive no views who you know but I
think people are too enjoying my brain
to spit it out
yeah especially with the cultural
differences okay right I think so I
think so I mean if you were if you were
to go to Germany and do the same bit
we'll call it about the party pooper
they would be like I don't understand
why this is right so and as Internet is
everywhere you know so the Germans may
see this party-pooper video but they
don't understand because they don't know
I think in America and perhaps as a
English places they are noticing and
they know that he they can see oh this
is a different perspective of the same
thing and so maybe that is why we have
success I don't understand the Internet
address you want but you now understand
what a party pooper is now I know it
yeah I know what that Jennifer is not
very interesting and if you were wanting
to have a good time you will not make an
invitation to Jennifer that's what I've
learnt right
[ __ ] yeah but you know in as red as I
kind of hear you're questioning I kind
of reflect on
our motive in asking Flula to be in the
intro to the bellybutton song okay who
could be the perfect guy to be in the
know about something that two idiots who
never even discovered their belly
buttons we we knew that you would be
funny but there was actually I guess
another thing which we never had to
discuss that was wouldn't it be funny if
a guy who's perceived as not only being
funny but being clueless to culture is
our source for knowing this thing that
everybody knows that you've got a belly
button right this is our Authority the
so yeah is there a sense of people kind
of is that a sensitivity to you do you
do you get concern that people see you
as an outsider who just doesn't doesn't
get it and they find me funny
oh no I for me it is if I am seeing that
people are enjoying my sings fun from
anyway past for any Angus I don't care
like I like to spread my energies this
is my goal is let me spread it and if
people enjoy it great if they like oh
you are silly dumb goose face okay
that's a nice reaction I think it's most
set if you make something and nobody is
caring like hey here's my here's my soup
and then you come back who is eating the
soup nobody yeah that's sad you don't
want that yeah it's a difference between
not being of being in intelligence and
kind of a cultured difference there are
two different things that I think in a
lot of people's minds and say well this
guy can't have his English is not as
great as mine or his his culture
understanding is not the same as mine
they equate that with unintelligent yeah
but for me it is like export exposing
right so many times I've not yet you're
exposing for these do co2 your phrases
to your to your idioms so for me they
are new also sometimes I am
understanding what it is meaning but it
is so stupid to me right it's like what
why are we putting the proof in the
pudding so you're the smart one would
know I don't know I'm only seeing it in
a different you have seen I think that's
the
my point exactly is that it we
instinctively equate those things like
when I go to France and you know all of
a sudden I'm like I think people are
perceiving me as an idiot because I feel
like I'm not smart I can't communicate
and I get really frustrated yeah me oh
so here I do also it's a familiar sign
from heaven in flesh encounter it is
always I'm a constant making a switch to
English and that is a frustration if you
are in France and you have a feeling you
cannot express then you are feeling like
an idiot at least that is how I am
feeling it's hurting my brain to my
constants which constant constant
constant but you have it but you the
thing is is you haven't let it prevent
you from coming up the people and
talking to him you know like I we met it
was a VidCon VidCon I met yeah yeah and
you know and I you know that's one thing
but just the fact having the courage to
to make the copper tube video comfort
yeah and and and put yourself out there
in that way and then people start
perceiving it hey you know one of the
reasons that I think it works so well is
that YouTube is such a personality based
thing people fall in love with
personalities it helps if you're all so
talented and you've got that you've got
good ideas like the auto-tune thing that
something people can latch on to and
that works really well in the context of
YouTube but yeah it's I we're just we're
excited to see it to see it growing
because I mean right as soon as we met
you and we looked at all your stuff we
were like this guy is he's we think he's
about we think flugel is about to blow
up
oh wow because it's just it's a and I
think it's cool I think we're you're in
you're in the process of that that
happening one of the things you're doing
is you're collaborating with a lot of
people you know we see you in a lot of
different videos you you out you
obviously have people show up to be a
part of the auto-tune series but you're
in like grace and mamrie and Hannah's
videos you know what is the how did you
get to know them and and how are you
collaborating with them yeah well no
that's - I'm learning that is too good
time first of all it's a very great
community to YouTube place like
laughs all these people to meet those
guys I'm trying to Oh grace so grace she
did cover when she had to show some
musical with
daily Daily Grace at the Petit long legs
so she was making it she have a sexy
Friday show sexy Friday sexy and so I
was in it because steady long legs and
so this was to start so that is how yeah
and so that was that was the first video
of yours that was going viral that was
the sort of most bigoted the first one
was I'm in Germany oppa poodles when I
was deported then this receive some
views then it was a half a million
probably yeah that's right yeah yeah
yeah and so then was today I make the
song for Dirk Nowitzki my hero
Herman Mouse's and then was I think
daddy longlegs was number like the
number three one that was receiving some
views and then graces
you know she's pushing that one yeah
helping oh that was great and then I was
in a studio audience for what's trending
do you know the show what's trending and
I was just watching it and then Hannah
was in the show and during so sure she
looked at me like we are cousins and so
I was like oh yeah I know also you and
then we did hug and then have some sure
I can know you from from Teddy Long Legs
and so we did hang out yeah and so then
in Denton those guys did show me and we
did meet
maimry from this okay yeah yeah yeah
they are very great I like she's got the
UNC connection too yeah and then we did
connect because Tar Heel saw she was
also yeah yeah very fun now okay this is
a little bit off-topic but I've got to
ask you about it that's to it you're the
first non-american to participate and
metal in the redneck games hiya that
stretches which is where are they it's
in Texas right in Texas from Dallas it
was like into as you say the boondocks
right it was nowhere oh wow who is it
where we don't know we are I was there
was a television crew and they did come
and they're like we want you to also
maybe participate participation so I did
with my cousin Jurgen
it was the mattress
trunk they're calling it it was throwing
a mattress so you must throw the
mattress from the sir from the truck
from the truck
the hidden bed the bed so you sit in the
bed of the truck and up you throw the
mattress with with the teeter part of a
two-man team two persons yeah yeah yeah
and I will we were third place third
place so we we danced once we prawns
that so it's a medal but almost not
metal so we was lucky
were you I mean were you welcomed in
that crowd or were they like that get
these guys they liked it I think it's
always nice a little spice right yeah we
are look at all the pepper where's the
salt we need some salt yeah yeah how far
did you throw the mattress I do not it
was probable yeah nine meters perhaps
eight eight meters prude I would say I
was I with some more with push-ups and
bench press in this time okay yeah you
were pumped up I was pretty pumped
yeah what other video started to pop for
you next it was you would get into the
auto-tune after like the daddy-longlegs
and kind of the cultural idiom
differences yeah don't the next thing
those words the next so two idioms was
caught like a fish in a barrel was the
one people did enjoy like shooting fish
in a barrel
those was nice or happy as a clam also
was weird and then yadda Auto Tunes and
you started that afterward
yeah Auto Tunes I think I was realizing
I'm a musician and people don't know it
so what may I do that is interesting for
me and then also perhaps for other
people and that was Auto Tunes so I was
starting to make more of those and that
became like the big thing on your
channel yeah it's interesting they are
so hot I must do more we must make our
nice automaker it will make it it would
be fun when you're doing other things
too like you're trying the 10 minute
I've got 10 minutes tell me what to do
tell you what to do yeah yeah so I will
make this I will tweet like I have ten
minutes with with always a jacuzzi tell
me what to do and some sort I said yeah
make make the film jaws so I did make
the film gels in the jacuzzi with the
hair very real
he was that by the way that was a
neighbor friend not really that was a
hotel there's no tent on that bag no no
tents no time for tents dear where is
that that was in like Malibu or some
this was in a Mexico Mexico I did have a
so a private teacher kick and they said
we will like for you to come to have a
teacher kick for our family for a
birthday party
and so yeah I know very strange so I
will reenact secure yeah it's very weird
I have a strange force I do not know why
but and it was in Cabo San Lucas and it
was a day like we love you we will like
you we are large fans
our daughters having a birthday but you
must teach at the party so did it Flum
it down like how old is the daughter she
was 18 okay yeah yeah so not so weird
yeah yeah that would be awkward yeah I
don't know 18 year old daughter it's
kind of weird for now a different reason
definitely hey Dad your dad flew me down
so what's your finally legal this day oh
ouch no no no it for surprise it was
like surprise here watcher who is it
Lula ah ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba BOM
well and was it like the daughter and
the mom and the dad and you like the
four of you kind of dancing
well no that was one song we did have
that one and but most that was seen see
Music Factory we did this but every what
a party children and not children big
party big PR 80 100 80 100 people yeah
well no I was like some rich people
perhaps I think yeah how many hard
drives you get for that one yeah oh yeah
executive it was a hard drive with
Bitcoin on it you know it but we've had
the privilege of experiencing your
deejaying you know that the playlist
live collective that's Fri it's party
and I gotta say you move a lot more than
any DJ that I've ever that I've ever
seen and and I don't mean bobbing the
head but I mean leaving the station
yeah and entering the dance floor yeah
yeah did it happen several times most of
the time
I feel yeah for me that is the most
important part if you are DJ do you not
enjoy the music that you play yeah yeah
but I was just worried that you leave
this the word it was there what do you
call it the turntables yeah
the home you just spin home yeah you you
leave home base yeah yeah someone could
come in fill the spot oh but this is a
you must have to you must have a trust
after group I guess yeah you're right it
has not happened before so you normally
leave you're going dance I have a go and
dance you dance with this 18 year old
girl well with friends everyone must
watch we're not it's or not like me and
lady and like we are private closet
that's awkward it is public everyone may
see ok yeah yeah yeah yeah so what are
your what's your plan what are what
what's next for your channel and from
here on out I mean you don't have an
album more series on your YouTube
channel so I'm making right now an EP oh
yeah yeah so that's for me that is five
songs and just like these are songs that
maybe are more like sounding like a
professional sound like many times I
make weird songs that I just want to
make it let me get it out you know like
I have a song about leftovers and I just
did make it in my refrigerator was
sitting in it and it make the song boom
release we are done but these are like I
want to make like real songs that are
sounding more like you know professional
so this is this is fun goal this will
occur hope to the next some months in
the channel more outer tunes they are
they are they are sometime consumed for
me but I love cells very much more vlogs
I'm now starting something German with a
German with Flula so I am teaching some
German phrasing okay to the audience
flip the script so to speak Wow what do
you call that series German wizard
German with Flula yeah I guess yeah
that's the name and so I want to do I'm
doing more of these we must do one a
very easy today at it one a shiz Fort
Lee which means poop friendly so it is
how we say in in German if someone's
like oh how are you oh so nice
oh you look great like we cannot see it
in the camp we have no cameras here but
it is Faye they're not being sincere
yeah yeah tries fine fish poop friendly
hoop friendly well you know yeah yeah
but so we are teaching this I want to do
more after as a serious I guys what
pointless oh that's what she is
so try Streisand lish finally perfect
it's good guys finally yeah that's good
that's really good really yeah try
stylish finally yeah the most difficult
I've seen with Americans is to CH yeah
pointless
finally yeah yeah yeah most Americans is
as hard as lick they will say lick not
leash and that is for us it's like the
THS sometimes hard for us yeah in
American like that's English sorry
that's hard okay yeah but anyway yeah
most more things more items are coming
okay
and and you've got this camera here yeah
yeah just like what so what's going on
so right now my friend Alex he's filming
his making call calling it the flu
Elementary doc who a documentary about
Flula do me he's just thinking I have a
strange life it's like you have a very
strange life perhaps maybe I will film
it and so I say yes okay so maybe your
biscuits is a scene in your documentary
you know it and then we will get some
cheese and have some eeeh Triscuits
snack for your ma well think about it we
make all kinds of puns about their
biscuits so I mean you want to add
Triscuits in fact you know what we could
get Triscuits as a sponsor
oh I'd be willing for it for a pretty
penny maybe for a few hard drives to
change - to your Triscuits do well let's
work on it
MLA you know like Triscuits good if if
Triscuits follows you you can probably
work something out and also introduce us
to mix-a-lot oh I will do both but MC
build yeah it's time for you to sign the
table thanks for hanging out and it's
been good to get to know you yes thank
you guys this is very great I'm a sign
your table
[Music]
there you have it our ear biscuit with
Flula clearly a hilarious dude how self
aware of how hilarious he is it's still
question I'm not sure I'm not sure I
will be I will be pondering Flula for
the rest of the evening hopefully I
won't have any dreams about him because
it'll just be this German guy singing
about heifers so what did he say what is
the lyric to that I can I can ever
remember it
you sewed naked cows and I'm gonna move
cow
you are so dairy something like a heifer
fairy yeah something something like that
but we should get him to DJ our birthday
party in Cabo San Lucas that's pretty
great yeah I will you know what maybe we
can stop a little short of that and just
have him like DJ like a work Christmas
party or does DJ every like one of our
Wednesdays or any day of the week really
it's fluid day at rhett and Link here he
is he's back well you know like I said I
wasn't blowing smoke when I feel like
we're talking - we talked to Flula at a
time when I feel like his career is is
on an upswing you know we talked to a
lot of people who are we're talking
about oh when you bust it out on YouTube
and oh seven or whatever it's
interesting to talk to somebody who it's
happening with him right now there's
this sense that this is a big year you
start seeing if I show little I'll show
up and in all these different videos and
everyone you talk to is like that dude
is so funny you know I'm gonna fly him
to Cabo San Lucas yeah and you know you
gotta wonder what that what that girl's
parents thought when she was like hey
Dad
we got to have this German DJ at my
birthday party in Cabo there's nothing
for you daughter he's like okay let me
look this guy up okay he thinks is his
music isn't like a hamster sure well fly
min but Jack in payment hard drives all
right yeah so tweet at Flula let him
know what you thought of his ear biscuit
also hashtag ear biscuits when you're
speaking to us on the Twitter we enjoy
your feedback and also value your review
on the iTunes so thank you for doing
that
and if you are associated with Triscuits
in any way I won't I will not say this
is an official endorsement or a request
for sponsorship but I will say I love
Triscuits I love all the varieties I've
never had a variety of Triscuit that
I've not thoroughly enjoyed they're
especially good when you're camping you
know when you're just out camping and
you got some salami and some cheese and
throw them on a Triscuit or when you're
camping on someone's balcony yeah or
when you're not camping and see how good
this could be Triscuit yeah all right
thank you for being a loyal your biscuit
listen here it always gets us choked up
when we think about you thank you and we
will deliver another one to you next
week can we count on you boom I knew we
could
[Music]
[Music]